i
[Música]
'francia baraja entrar en un tercer
confinamiento para frenar el acelerado
avance de la pandemia de kobe 19
agravado por la circulación de la
variante británica del virus el
principal asesor científico del gobierno
señaló que el confinamiento debería
iniciar en febrero
de lo contrario habría una situación
extremadamente difícil a mediados de
marzo
el presidente de méxico andrés manuel
lópez obrador se encuentra bajo
tratamiento médico tras dar positivo por
el coronavirus el mandatario de 67 años
reportó síntomas leves pero preocupa a
los expertos por su historial de
problemas cardíacos el contagio se
produjo en la semana más letal de la
pandemia para mexico que ya roza los 150
mil muertos
se cumple el décimo aniversario del
inicio de la revolución egipcia parte de
la primavera árabe que sacó del poder a
hosni mubarak a 10 años de las masivas
movilizaciones el país vive bajo la
sombra del gobierno militar de abdel
fatal si sí que llegó al poder tras el
golpe de estado en 2013 tenemos
información desde el cairo
gracias por continuar con nosotros en
france 24 soy valentina torre sánchez
iniciamos este informativo en francia
donde el avance de la pandemia de kobe
19 agravado por la presencia de la
variante británica ha forzado al
gobierno a discutir un posible tercer
confinamiento pese a que hasta el
momento no se ha tomado una decisión el
comité de expertos que asesora al
presidente de manuel mccomb recomienda
que haya un nuevo aislamiento en febrero
para evitar una situación extremadamente
difícil a mediados de marzo
estamos todos muy preocupados porque
sabemos que esta variante británica se
va a instalar y si llega a un punto
significativo en la epidemia con una
alta circulación del virus serán las
peores consecuencias así que es verdad
que estamos viendo la información en una
base diaria para saber cuándo es el
momento apropiado para un confinamiento
usted sabe que ahora somos lo
suficientemente afortunados por poder
predecir las cosas en el último año una
vez que hay números exponenciales no se
puede parar nada hoy gracias a los
modelos de los epidemiólogos podemos
predecir tan pronto como la base de la
curva así que tenemos que tomar medidas
tan pronto como sea posible para evitar
el golpe y evitar un pico alto pero no
tan pronto tampoco porque usted sabe
cuan terrible es el confinamiento para
todos
y desde parís nuestra corresponsal erika
olavarría nos da más detalles al
respecto
la situación sanitaria en francia del
coi 19 está estabilizada desde diciembre
del año pasado hay 24.000 nuevos casos
diarios 500 decesos diarios en promedio
obviamente sin embargo en la población
hay un rumor de que va a haber un nuevo
confinamiento y esto porque el
presidente manuel macro no debe presidir
el próximo miércoles un tercer gabinete
sanitario desde que se inició la
pandemia y parece que el gobierno está
muy presionado sobre todo por los
científicos para decretar un nuevo
confinamiento ellos tienen miedo de las
nuevas variantes de ccoo y 19 sobre todo
de la británica y no quieren tener una
crisis sanitaria como la que está
viviendo el reino unido- pero el
gobierno está preocupado de la reacción
social que puede generar un nuevo
confinamiento y de la reacción económica
por lo mismo el ejecutivo está esperando
los resultados para ver qué efectos ha
tenido el toque de queda a las 6 de la
tarde que estamos viviendo en francia y
también para ver con qué rapidez se
contagia efectivamente en francia la
nueva cepa lo otro es que el ejecutivo
francés tiene seguro es que de hacer un
tercer confinamiento las escuelas
seguiría
abiertas
vamos a eeuu porque el presidente joe
biden restablecerá la prohibición de
entrada al país de viajeros procedentes
de la unión europea reino unido y brasil
y también serán vetadas las personas que
lleguen desde sudáfrica y que no sean
ciudadanos estadounidenses se trata de
un nuevo esfuerzo del gobierno por
frenar la pandemia que ya deja más de 25
millones de contagiados
la decisión de bailén anula la medida
del ex presidente de donald trump del 18
de enero que levantaba las restricciones
de llegada a partir de este martes la
situación se presenta en medio de las
críticas de la nueva administración que
asegura que sus antecesores no tenían un
verdadero plan de distribución de
vacunas
el plan para distribuir la vacuna
particularmente fuera de los hogares
geriátricos y de los hospitales para la
comunidad en general en realidad no
existía cuando llegamos a la casa blanca
como todos en eeuu han visto la forma en
que las personas acceden a la vacuna es
caótica es limitada hemos visto este
factor por todo el país donde millones
de dosis han sido distribuidas cerca de
la mitad de las que se han aplicado así
que procesos para inyectar esas vacunas
es lo difícil ahí es donde estamos
rezagados como país y es ahí donde
estamos enfocados en la administración
bailén para acelerar eso y pasamos a
méxico porque el presidente de andrés
manuel lópez obrador informó que está
bajo tratamiento médico tras contagiarse
del virus
el mandatario de 67 años que se declaró
optimista informó que ha presentado
síntomas leves sin embargo su historial
de presión alta y problemas cardíacos
mantiene en alerta a su equipo médico el
diagnóstico de lópez obrador se conoce
cuando el país está a punto de rebasar
las 150 mil muertes
el presidente notificó a través de sus
cuentas oficiales y en redes sociales
que el día de hoy se confirmó infectado
y con signos y síntomas para efectos de
kobe 19 felizmente el presidente se
encuentra en estos momentos con que se
encuentra estable los signos y síntomas
de enfermedad son leves es decir en este
momento él está expresando un cobit leve
se encuentra resguardado en su domicilio
israel es el país donde más rápido
avanza la campaña de vacunación según
datos oficiales más del 25 por ciento de
la población ya ha sido inmunizada la
nación combina esta estrategia con un
nuevo cierre del tráfico aéreo total y
un severo confinamiento sin embargo
organizaciones internacionales condenan
la negativa del gobierno israelí de
vacunar a la población palestina tal y
como exigen los acuerdos de oslo de 1990
detalles en el informe de luís muñoz
israel cerrado por coronavirus desde la
medianoche del lunes al martes el país
prohibirá el tráfico aéreo durante una
semana tan solo habrá excepciones
humanitarias el objetivo es evitar que
entre alguna de las nuevas variantes de
kobe 19 la diferencia de lo que se dice
estamos por delante del mundo entero
ningún país ha hecho lo que vamos a
hacerlo a sur cerrado por aire y por
tierra el país continúa en un severo
confinamiento hasta febrero lo que sí
que avanzan son las vacunas israel ya ha
inoculado al 25% de su población de 9
millones desde este domingo se pueden
vacunar mayores de 40 años y también con
permiso paterno adolescentes entre 16 y
18 años de este modo podrán volver a la
escuela y realizar sus exámenes
las vacunas ya están aquí tengo mis
exámenes finales en unas pocas semanas
así que sentía que tenía que vacunarse
sin embargo la vacunación despierta
críticas internacionales israel se niega
a inocular a la población palestina
amnistía internacional human right watch
no han emplazado a los acuerdos de oslo
de 1990 para vacunar a los palestinos
según éstos israel debe cooperar para
combatir epidemias
condenamos el racismo del estado de
ocupación se jactan de la rapidez de
vacunar a sus ciudadanos y descuidan la
responsabilidad de inocular a las
personas bajo ocupación tal mismo auto
niega denuncias que se suman a la
dificultad que está teniendo israel con
su población ultra-ortodoxa ésta
significa poco más del 10 por ciento de
sus habitantes sin embargo se niegan a
obedecer el confinamiento y rechazan
cualquier vacunación
y nueva zelanda confirmó su primer caso
de kobe 19 tras más de dos meses sin
contagios se trata de una mujer de 56
años que viajó a españa y países bajos
por trabajo y que dio positivo a la
variante sudafricana del virus las
autoridades investigan como lo con
trabajo pues la mujer llegó al país el
pasado 30 de diciembre y durante su
cuarentena dio negativo a las dos
pruebas anteriores ya fueron
identificadas 15 personas con las que
tuvo contacto cercano y dos de ellas
resultaron negativas
cambiamos de tema y vamos a egipto que
cumple 10 años del surgimiento de las
masivas protestas callejeras que sacaron
del poder al entonces presidente hosni
mubarak
a continuación una mirada retrospectiva
a los eventos que se han desarrollado en
la última década
plaza tahir el corazón del levantamiento
popular de egipto a partir del 25 de
enero de 2011 miles de manifestantes se
reunieron bajo la atenta mirada del
ejército pidiendo un cambio inmediato
durante lo que llamaron un día de rabia
bajo la creciente presión de las
protestas callejeras el presidente hosni
mubarak renunció y salió del cairo con
su familia el 11 de febrero espero que
algún día esta revolución de enero pueda
traernos lo que hemos pedido ban
libertad justicia social y dignidad se
celebraron elecciones legislativas y
para la sorpresa de todos los islamistas
obtuvieron dos tercios de los escaños de
los diputados en un punto de inflexión
histórico el candidato de los hermanos
musulmanes mohamed morsi se convirtió en
el primer presidente elegido
democráticamente
morsi prestó juramento el 30 de junio de
2012 sólo unas semanas después del
juicio sin precedentes de mubarak pero
este breve experimento de democracia
terminó en julio de 2013 con el
derrocamiento y arresto de morse
a pesar de las protestas en las calles
un nuevo régimen autoritario respaldado
por el ejército tomó el control en mayo
de 2014 con el 97% de los votos el ex
ministro de defensa el general
abdelfatah al sisi fue elegido
presidente el parlamento adoptó
rápidamente una nueva constitución que
fortalecía los poderes del ejército una
al cis y envalentonado lanzó una feroz
campaña para reprimir las voces
disidentes
las ong denunciaron violaciones a los
derechos humanos tras la detención de
miles de partidarios de morse una década
después de la revolución a pesar de una
mejora en la economía las ambiciones
democráticas de egipto aún no se han
cumplido pero su economía ha recibido un
impulso
para ampliar esta información conectamos
con nuestra corresponsal en el cairo
nuria tesón nuria buenos días como
conmemora egipto los 10 años del inicio
de la revolución
de ninguna manera lo cierto es que hace
instantes acabo de pasar por la plaza de
tánger y para intentar hacer nuestra
posición desde allí es imposible la
policía me lo ha impedido y eso muestra
muy claramente que el régimen no tiene
ninguna intención no sólo no de
conmemorar sino de enterrar lo más
posible esta celebración de hecho hoy
que es el día de la policía el
presidente abdel fatah él sí sí está
previsto que asista a la conmemoración
de esa de esa fiesta y precisamente fue
este día cuando se marcaron las
protestas de enero de 2011 para luchar o
para protestar contra la policía para
pedir paz para pedir libertad democracia
justicia social para pedir dignidad algo
que con el paso de los años el régimen
no ha ahorrado en esfuerzos para acabar
con ello así que los que participaron en
aquellas protestas los que han seguido
luchando los años posteriores incluso
las familias de los que han terminado
sus días en la cárcel o en el exilio
están celebrando el día en la intimidad
lo están recordando algunos intentarán
por la plaza aunque será muy difícil
porque las fuerzas de seguridad tienen
toda la zona controlada desde hace
varios días
diez años después quedan vivos algunos
de los ideales por los que se luchaba
podría el país vivir una nueva
revolución
por supuesto y lo más importante y lo
que reconoce en la mayor parte de los
activistas y miembros de la sociedad
civil es que se rompió la barrera del
miedo se perdió el miedo a hablar sobre
todo y se ganó en confianza a los
egipcios recuperaron su país sintieron
egipto les pertenecía y que podían
reclamarlo así me lo explicaba gamal ahí
hace solamente unos días el abogado que
fundó la red árabe para la información
de derechos humanos pero además muchos
otros activistas como los que estáis
mostrando en estas imágenes acabo de ver
a saná se iguala al fatá siguen luchando
siguen protestando para que las demandas
del 25 de enero se vuelvan a app
se vuelvan a conseguir se vuelvan a
mantener y si al menos se consiga pedir
a pesar de la represión y a pesar de de
la connivencia o de la complicidad de
occidente que sí se respeten los
derechos humanos es muy importante
recordar que una de las principales
demandas de aquellos días fue la
dignidad y la justicia social algo que
no se ha conseguido a pesar de que se
produzcan leves mejores a la economía la
situación de los egipcios es dramática a
nivel de calle la gente tiene muchas
dificultades para sobrevivir
económicamente y son muchos los egipcios
que todavía siguen denunciando y siguen
pidiendo al régimen que se produzcan
esos avances que soñaron contener el 25
de enero que se han quedado de alguna
manera en suspenso pero qué
que siguen ilusionando a muchos moría
muchas gracias por toda esta información
y este análisis y ahora vamos a europa
porque fuentes diplomáticas indicaron
que turquía y grecia retomaron
negociaciones que buscan resolver la
disputa marítima que mantienen ambas
naciones en el mediterráneo oriental por
la explotación de hidrocarburos ambos
países son integrantes de la otan y han
llevado a cabo 60 rondas de
conversaciones entre 2002 y 2016 con muy
pocos avances a principios del mes ambas
naciones acordaron retomar los diálogos
en estambul lo que fue considerado una
muestra del interés de turquía en
mejorar sus relaciones con la unión
europea que apoya a grecia en esta
disputa
finalizamos en china donde las
autoridades informaron que encontraron
los restos de nueve de los 22 mineros
que habían quedado atrapados tras una
explosión en una mina de la provincia de
shandong el pasado 10 de enero ayer 11
de ellos fueron rescatados sanos y
salvos y ya se había confirmado la
muerte de uno de los miembros del grupo
con el hallazgo se eleva a 10 el número
de fallecidos y aún se desconoce el
paradero y la suerte de uno de los
mineros
fin del informativo recuerden que pueden
ampliar toda la información en nuestra
web france24 puntocom
[Música]